get it together in the new party on the
data right so that's not vocal a bit
before web as an online learning system
that's it's very different in many ways
from what you're used to it also has a
lot of other tricks that you'll see
which are very which push the extremes
of what's possible because he's kind of
driven by the kind of research that I
was doing at the time that I was working
on it
one of these is large-scale linear
regression this was the first terascale
learning system it's designed to operate
in Hadoop environment on a thousand
nodes another one is active learning I
was talking to
Claudio just a moment ago about active
learning there's a number of active
learning and active learning what
happens is you're you're learning album
is kind of guiding which which points
you want to have labeled it goes out and
says oh I would really like to have this
point labeled can you label that for me
and the goal there is to try to figure
out how to get good performance with
this few labels as possible another kind
is learning reductions so back in the
day when I first started doing research
and machine learning
everybody was creating their a different
learning album for every different
problem and that kind of seems chaotic
so I would spend a lot of time trying to
figure out how to turn one one problem
into another problem so that the
solution on on the problem you reduced
to would give you a good solution to the
problem that you started from
so VW operates through reductions to a
large extent there's a suit everything
kind of reduces down to a base learning
algorithm
there's also learning to search so maybe
I should update the name here nowadays
they call this reinforcement learning
back in the day it wasn't called that it
was called learning to search the idea
there is that you have you have a
simulator and inside of this simulator
you making discrete to see and at the
end of a sequence of decisions you get
some sort of a feedback about how good
the outcome was and now your goal is to
improve on some policy that you start
with right based upon this reinforcement
feedback so we've done a lot of tricks
with this to make it so you can
you can do complex structure prediction
problems like dependency parsers using
this kind of approach it gives you good
performance but I think the real value
of this is actually in relatively ad-hoc
pipelines if you have a long pipeline of
decisions that you want to make which
has some feedback at the end you can
start optimizing for that long pipeline
even if parts of that pipeline are code
or some other process and then parts of
it are learned you can have a mixture of
code and learning in a manner which is
relatively unique another area I've been
thinking about a lot is how do you
choose one of K things in time
logarithmic in K if this is a research
area of course but if you wanted to
build a face recognize different
everybody on earth you'd really want it
to run in a logarithmic time because
there's a lot of people on earth all
right you probably want to apply it many
times so there's several different
algorithms inside of V W now for doing
this and and they actually do a few
things at times then the last topic here
is contextual bandits so what I was
planning to go through for today is
primarily the first thing and the last
thing so connectional bandits are sort
of one step reinforcement learning so
what happens if you care about the
immediate reward for whichever decision
you make because that is the kind of
reinforcement learning what actually
gets used in the real world in which
which does great things when you can use
it so are there questions about this as
I said if you feel free to ask questions
because I'm entirely happy to go into
any other direction that interests
everyone
okay so just a few high-level things is
a BSD license it has a fair number of
people who are using it it's been used
by a large number of different companies
there's an automated test suite is a
github repository you can essentially do
all I all modes there's an executable
that's what I primarily use but there's
a library also and you can connect the
ports and you can talk to it as a daemon
there's also an input format
now the input format can kind of handle
sparse data of the sort that you might
be used to but also a much more rich
input format where you actually just
feed it in raw text and it will do
something interesting I'll show you a
bit more about that later it's mostly
C++ but their bindings you know the
languages python c-sharp and Java
bindings are all pretty good alright so
yes this is an open source project
obviously new people have contributed to
it over time and so I thank all of them
because it's made things much better
than I could ever do myself ok so let's
start with online linear learning so
this is just kind of what the baseline
default is in Buffalo of it so what
happens is let's see if I can do this
yes so you get some features and then
you make a prediction
and then you will observe some label
answers here this work okay good so you
get some features you make a linear
prediction and then you observe a label
and now you update your weights right
and there's a number of different ways
to update the way it's in there's many
variations but this is the core idea
there's also you can do logistic instead
these these are kind of minor variations
and all the minor variations you might
expect are supported okay so as an
example if you're optimizing squared
loss what you might do is compute the
gradient of squared loss and then update
in the negative gradient direction which
is exactly with this they would do right
where ADA here is just some learning
rate now if you do that just that it
ends up not working terribly well but in
terms of that if you if you optimize
your the way you do the learning exactly
so if you with variations on this you
can make it work pretty well okay so let
me show you an example this is a skill
here all right so
this is the kind of data that you might
be used to so there's just labels one to
label one or two there's features so
feature 13 has value 3.9 ten to the
minus two is a whole bunch of features
for each individual thing this is a
document classification data set our cb1
okay so if we look at this in more
detail
there's make that a little bit more
readable
why put 1 gigabytes we can ask how many
lines are there takes a little while
about 760 thousand lines okay I'm bored
all right so then what we can try to
learn so we just want to run through the
data set learning we're running on line
so we're going through each individual
example USO's faster than WC um all
right so we went through each individual
example Oh a microphone we went through
each individual example okay and now now
I need to tell you a trick so the trick
is okay
if what you did was you did train and
then test in the normal Bachelet way be
very slow you wouldn't want to do that
all right so instead what you do is you
test one ahead of where you train right
and that also gives you an unbiased
estimate of performance and so this is
the performance since the beginning this
is the performance since the last line
we're printing out with some sort of
exponential back-off one of these is the
prediction in one of these is the truth
this is the example number that we're on
this is the number of years that were
associated with at individual example we
finished the run we went through seven
hundred eighty-one thousand examples of
781227
our average loss was point zero five and
I remember where this includes the
average from the beginning when we
didn't know anything all of our
parameters were initialized to zero
yeah so we keep going there about 60
million features here
so overall yeah we got a decent result
and we did it in about three seconds
which is not bad
okay so this is something I should coast
road you know ten years ago because we
had this working ten years ago and and
there's a lot of tricks and things that
have been layered on since then to make
it better in many ways so one of those
is we have more sophisticated update
rule which allows us to get someone
better performance another one is this
hashing trick so let me show you this
yeah
so this is the data set in as raw form
as is available
essentially we have the same labels 1 &
2 but now you have sub words there stems
because the data set so I can get it in
the Ross format is stem some stock words
have been removed but these are the
actual words and the documents are
trying to classify as the business
documents or not right okay so we can go
and let's do just this one so we're
running through going through things
pretty fast our performance ended up a
little bit worse here 0.057 I should get
me our performance ended up a little bit
worse but the raw data so we've
eliminated a lot of steps in our
pipeline and now we can start doing
things like sending oh I would like to
play with engrams I'm gonna have
diagrams so I'm gonna I mean
so how did this work so you had the
individual words I used a hash function
to compute an index into a parameter
array for each individual word and it
treated in a non specified value as 1
all right so that gives you a bag of
words representation and then you can
just work with that I can change the
number of bits in the hash function
changing the number of parameters to be
24 rather than 18 which is the default
it gives me a little bit more parameters
I can say oh I want to work with by
grams and I want to allow skips of 4
between the elements of the diagram and
then I can is just saying I want to
print out the binary loss I can also say
I'm gonna adjust the learning rate down
a little bit the default learning rate
is two point five point two five ends up
working a little tiny bit better okay so
now if I do this it's running through
things it's a little bit slower now
because it has quite a bit more features
that is generating on the fly but it's
still it's still pretty fast it's at 22
and the more importantly the error rate
is getting lower and lower and lower
all right so almost there
right so let me push this up a little
bit put in JIRA for five which is really
good performance in this data set
so just by switching to working with the
raw data and playing around with exactly
what tweeters we wanted suddenly the
performance became much better than what
you could get with any sort of tf-idf
linear on the original words type of
thing so so this is this is kind of the
core a VW are there questions about this
yeah what's that no this is just zero
one loss so I think if I get rid of this
then just a squared loss which is the
default then you can also do logistic or
whatever you want yeah usually
yeah
so for every word you compute a hash you
use a 24-bit hash here and that 24-bit
hash is a number which looks up a point
in an array and that that print the
parameter at that point in the array is
what gets used when you're learning for
that individual work now there's a
complexity here which is that we're
we're also doing here we're also doing
by grams with skips and what's happening
there is you have the hash of one word
and you have the hash of another word
and you combine them right to get a new
hash and so that it's very
straightforward amazingly useful trick
in life and it might grant because it
lets you work with raw data in a way
which is just much more natural than
other approaches
yeah so yes so we're not we're not
manufacturing into information you could
work with by grams and then do a tf-idf
transformation on it and then try to get
good performance and you probably will
get good performance it would be similar
to what you get here right this gets you
most of the performance that you could
possibly get on these kinds of linear
sparse text type things which is where
BW is really good yeah with very minimal
effort another question is there a
simple way of we're adding a word
embedding so there is a way of adding a
word embedding I wouldn't call it simple
but basically you can you can there's an
option you can feed it a dictionary and
it will substitute things into in from
the dictionary at at runtime okay
right so we can get pretty good
performance okay so now another question
yeah
so we're remember we're considering
skips so we're doing diagrams for
adjacent words then also two words with
a star in between and towards with two
stars in between yeah that's actually
correct though because we're only
counting the number of none of that
actually appear right so
they're 344 million but if you think
about it if I give you let's imagine
that we're not doing skips it's like a
Templar so you have a sequence of 100
words how many by grams are there in
that Hut secret 700 words 99 so if you
allow skips in it gets a little bit
larger but doesn't grow fast right the
set of potential by grams is extremely
large but the set of items you actually
encounter is not too large and so one of
the things that happens when you're
doing this this hashing thing is the end
of learning a relatively robust
predictor and so back in the day when I
was at Yahoo we would use seems like it
you wanted a robust predictor because it
meant that an adversary couldn't come in
and you know pick a word over and over
again it would break your system that
easy
okay so so what do we want online
learning what why is this interesting so
you get very fast convergence to a
pretty good predictor so I think that
often if you want the very last bit of
performance then you don't want to be
doing online learning but but it gets
you into the neighborhood of the best
possible very quickly it's also very
random efficient right so I guess these
days the matter and when a laptop is but
they'll be large so I can easily fit the
data set into RAM but on the other hand
I can also show up data sets which are
much larger than Ram through the
learning system without without it even
being bothered so there's a duality
between online learning algorithms and
online optimization algorithms so many
of you are operating in a batch learning
paradigm and what that means is that you
really are doing online optimization if
you're doing kind of a online gradient
descent type thing because you run over
the dataset over and over and over again
in order to get the best performance as
you can so I guess from a research
perspective studying online learning is
very interesting because it also means
you're studying online optimization
which means there's kind of two
applications that you can think about
but at the same time when you're helping
batch people when people helping people
solve batch problems through online
optimization you're also attacking how
to solve truly online learning problems
things where the data just comes at you
and the problem is shifting and you need
to be able to heat up that chip from the
problems in order to get the best
performance if it's possible
what I showed you is to consider a
descent it's one pass to gets a gradient
descent and it's using progressive
validation so that you can actually
discover what's what your performance is
as you're running through the data set
there's been a number of times when I
was doing some machine learning tasks
and I discovered that things were wrong
before I even finished one pass of the
data and then you know you can debug
very fast other questions yeah
you have to worry less about overfitting
in many ways because okay so if you're
passing over data many times then
overfitting becomes a much more serious
issue but progressive validation where
you're testing one ahead of where
training has the same kinds of unbiased
estimate properties as a test set so
that's really nice
it means that that you you you have an
unbiased estimate of the performance
that you're getting assuming the world
is coming from an iid source yeah
yeah so there's a lot of tricks actually
for debugging how many of them Esther
detail but alright so presently the
strings just get destroyed by the hash
function that go away right you can of
course say DISA shot it and then it will
print out exactly which examples are
going into the core learning algorithm
with the features in the in full text
form you can you can do the same thing
except you can do it in the model so you
can figure out which parameters
associated with which features in the
model now these are these are slower
right so you pay a penalty but but you
can do that right and then there's more
advanced forms of debugging available as
well
so for example you can say I want to do
some l1 organization and the VW felon
organization is applied on a per example
basis so you use it so there's ten to
the minus six so the small dental amount
of Eleanor Ava's ation on it for example
basis so then you run through your
performance is not really harmed it's a
small amount but but the parameters
which don't really matter they'll get
zeroed out right so this is more like
data scientists debugging we're trying
to figure out which which parameters
really matter you can do that in bulk
for all the parameters simultaneously
using l1 or at the grave ization
right and there's another trick which is
this is this is a true online learning
system and that means that the state of
the learning algorithm can be captured
you can save it to a file and then you
can start it up again and continue on
the stream and that means that if you
have something weird going on halfway
through your data set you can just cut
your dataset into two you can train on
that first half
save it with save resume and then load
up that that model and finish and get
the exact same result so you're
guaranteed to be able to that you're not
losing any information all right so so
those are the kinds of tricks which are
available
right so the last thing here is that
online learning is actually a thing
there's a number of problems where the
problem changes over time and because
the problem is changing over time you
really need to have a learning system
that can keep up with it okay so this is
half it's also the reinforcement
learning side and the key thing here is
that you really can't do online learning
without thinking about reinforcement
learning and the key reason here is that
the kind of information you get is just
different so many of you are used to
supervised learning and supervised
learning what happens is you have
unlabeled examples and you hire some
people to label things and then you
shove it into the Machine and out comes
a classifier right it's kind of a
supervised learning paradigm and you
know it's cool people done lots of
things imagenet but ok so one of the
supervised learning problem
supervisor now you think of it as a
solved if a human can tell you the right
answer many many times so you have a
thousand penguins in image same cases
supervisor Lee doesn't always meet that
contract but but this is what what
they're aiming for and this is this is I
think what a lot of
and now I want to tell you that this is
yeah so supervised learning is a tool to
teach some machine known things and now
it doesn't work when you really want to
do things that people don't know so
suppose that you want to do you want to
recommend news stories right the observe
it turns out to be quite hard so in a
standard pipeline what happens if you
construct features of the user in the
article and then you try to build a
predictor of the probability of a click
given the features of the user in the
article and then you choose the article
which maximizes the predictive
probability of a click and then you
place in an a/b test for a couple weeks
right and I've seen this fail on a
number of times and now the question is
why does it fail people peek
so there's sort of two things that I
think go wrong systematically so if you
create interesting to John Claudia knows
the answer to this yeah
what's the answer yes my wife is from
Ukraine but you wouldn't know that
unless you actually displayed a news
story about Ukraine or an editor
wouldn't know that must actually do my
background in great depth in detail
alright so this is this is one of the
real fundamental limitations of trying
to do supervised learning you need the
right signal to get the right answer the
supervised learning is not about getting
the right signal it's about using a
signal that has been given to it right
it's supervised learning is the process
of transferring information
the other thing is is that the the
problem is truly nonfiction area the set
of interesting news articles changes
rapidly over time this is real data
where we took our model from day one and
we need to put it on day two and day
three we observe that the place was
substantially worse so it's actually
this is one of those problems where
things shift rapidly and so you need to
use some sort of online learning to keep
up with what's going on in order to get
the best performance possible okay so
now the question is how do you actually
handle this and the answer is you think
about a different kind of feedback you
think about good and bad we're thinking
about some sort of reinforcement
feedback now the question is how do you
learn from a reward signal okay so this
is this is reinforcement learning so you
have some observation that comes in this
is a different paradigm from supervised
learning so you have an observation that
comes in you have that could be the user
history in the news stories you have a
learning algorithm with some policy
which seems to make a choice a different
with different news articles and then
you choose some news story and then
later on there's a feedback maybe
there's a click or no people there's no
quick right okay so I've worked on this
kinds of things for a long time and
there's a lot of fun examples of this
so backgammon was solved in 1990s before
I was a graduate student and then more
recently people have been playing with
Atari games and go look that's actually
quite a bit of fun
okay but but there's a caution here that
I want to make sure you're aware of
which is that these were all phd's doing
these problems and and it's super
necessary so that could be true so I'm
gonna tell you a simple problem that
breaks all the common reinforcement
learning algorithms so a boy goes
camping it's his first day camping he
has a fire and the pressure has died
down it's getting cold what he should do
is go to the logs and get a log and put
it on the fire right but okay so maybe
maybe these algorithms kind of do an
epsilon greedy exploration so you with
probably epsilon t steps away from the
fire right any and then maybe you know
epsilon squared he steps away even
further but things have to get even
colder and so the the obvious thing to
do is to step back to the fire right and
so the boy is warm for a while and then
you know the fire goes out right this is
a very simple problem and this is this
breaks comedy learning algorithm go and
read about the policy gradients
alternative see please speed it so you
if you if you have T steps to get to the
solution the probability of you getting
there is like 1 over epsilon to the T
the epsilon is 0.1 then you know and T
is 20 then you're looking at 10 to the
20 and that's not even a significant a
large problem right so this is the real
weakness of the multi-step reinforcement
one thing that you see in in the kind of
games people playing with right and then
people figure out ways around this and
if I had
I didn't prepare but I can go through a
bunch of tricks people use to get around
this okay so the one trick which I
really want to emphasize to you is a one
step reinforcement learning okay so if
it's this case that you're optimizing an
immediate reward then it turns out that
everything I just said is wrong you can
actually do this you can do it
systematically so that is really cool
that means that suddenly you can you can
widen the scope problem that you can
help to solve okay so this gets used it
gets I've had a number of papers on this
news recommendation when it's back at
Yahoo is the first application we've
worked on it's been used for ad choice
an ad format and education and music
recommendation and even robotics that's
a pretty cool one so in robotics you
would think that it's a very stateful
oops I need to write sorry yeah in
robotics you'd think it's a very
stateful problem and so you really need
to have a multi-step reinforcement
learning paradigm to solve it but in
robotics you also have a physical system
which is moving in the real world which
means that the samples are incredibly
expensive compared to computing in in a
GPU or whatever right and that means you
need to be as efficient as possible so
there's a division of labor that goes on
in this particular application what
happens here is the human figures out a
short term proxy reward for what they
want to optimize in the long term in the
learning out of them optimizes that and
that I think is something to think about
whenever you have some sort of long term
reward that you want to solve if you as
a human can figure out it that earns
data scientists can figure out how to
break it down say this is what I want to
optimize in the short term this is what
I want to put my T's next in the short
term and then we'll let the learning out
of them solve that
and then you can solve much more complex
problems and you might otherwise be able
to so oh yes and the last one is
wellness and health so is this things
like encouraging people to walk more
right it turns out these kinds of
techniques are are very useful there
okay so there's a tutorial that we
taught at 2ic months ago which is online
you can go and look at it there this is
all the technical details are there and
the algorithms are in VW okay so we are
in fact playing with a service you want
to play with a service like a cloud
service this is where maybe they get
smited by Google but
we were having fun come and join us
and I wanted to show you what this
actually looks like is an algorithm as
well let's go here not there this one
so how much time should they take that
okay so I'm going to show you got more
detail first before I show you the
allergies right sue
so I want to tell you just a little bit
more about how to think about this so
what we're thinking about a contextual
bandit problem it's not supervised
learning it's a one step reinforced
mourning also known as contextual
bandits so what happens in here
contextual bandits is you observe
features to choose an action in the
observe the reward and now you're trying
to maximize your expect to rework yeah
okay so there's a really cool trick okay
so let me tell you a little more so a
policy and a features two actions you
just think of a policy is just being a
classifier it's just that I mean I have
an additional meaning with it policy I
mean something which actually takes
actions in the real world for a
classifier it might be just advice for
some other system but here I mean
something which actually takes actions
in the real world so it could be no
network could be a decision tree and a
policy is a classifier that acts okay so
when you're trying to solve these
problems you're trying to gather the
information necessary to solve the
problem and so that in order to discover
that John is interested in articles
about Ukraine you have to actually
explore across different articles to
some extent to discover the information
that the John's should in the Train
so instead of having a deterministic
policy you actually have a randomized
policy and I don't mean a uniform random
policy although that's possible what I
mean is is the best algorithms are all
smart randomization so an example of
this would be something like you train
12 models and you randomize which model
you ask what to do
so maybe sometimes it's a space article
sometimes it's a food article mm-hmm
okay so now now here's the really cool
trick the really cool trick is okay so
we're collecting this randomized
information so we have the features we
have the action we have the probability
of the action that we took and we know
this because we drew from that
distribution at the time that we chose
the action and then we have the reward
click or not okay so you have this
information you have a data set of that
sort so this is different from a
supervised you set the supervisors that
you would just have the label Y and you
have some policy now the most basic
thing that you would like to do is know
how good is this policy since supervised
something this is easy you just apply
the policy and you see what your loss is
right just taking an average over your
data set here it's a little more tricky
right so the standard answer is you
ignore your data and you go and deploy
the policy in the real world that is the
standard answer right so it's called AV
testing and it's it's horribly
inefficient what you might want to do
instead use something like this we want
a value of policy we're going to take an
empirical average over the data of the
reward times an indicator function which
is 1 when the policy's chosen action is
equal to the random action divided by
the probability of the action so this
formula is reasonably intuitive to most
people you expect a large reward is good
you kind of expected paid into the data
which agrees with the policy
the division by P is maybe the least
intuitive part but it turns out this is
in fact an unbiased estimator so you can
prove that the expected reward of the
policies chosen action is equal to the
expectation of this estimator and that
proof fits on this slide what you can do
is you can say I am a researcher you
have to give me one little theorem right
what you get what the way you prove it
is you say look unimproved something for
every data point so I'm going to fix X
and R vector then the only randomization
left is the random draw of the action
right so we're gonna randomly draw the
action for each individual event we want
to know what what this estimator is for
the randomly drawn action so the
expectation is equal to the sum over the
actions of the probability the action
the probabilities cancel now and the sum
is going to cancel with the indicator
function you just end up with the reward
of the policies chosen action okay so
this is a proof it's unbiased and it's a
proof that sometimes that you can avoid
doing an a/b test to discover how good a
policy is so that that's fantastic
alright alright so this is an actual
example of using data
I think this line here is an offline
estimate of the system's actual
performance and this black line is the
actual performance of system on line
there's some differences because of
statistical variation but nevertheless
it's it's quite convergent and this is
the policy that we were competing with
which was an editor's trying to choose
news articles I was good okay so are the
questions about this this is a real
powerful trick in my experience and so I
want to want to emphasize that in many
situations if you collect the right data
you can avoid doing an a/b test to
discover whether or not you have a good
policy and furthermore will be able to
learn from that or they'll do much more
than all right so you pretty much of
this you'd have to go and look at the
tutorial I showed you earlier but the
ability to avoid Navy test is amazing in
terms of of how productive you can be in
solving a problem questions yeah
I believe multi-armed bandit
one limitation with that is that the
stationary assumptions to do that
so this is one of those things where
okay so there's the theory there's
actually two branches of theory one of
them is when the world is iid and the
other one is when the world is
adversarial so the adversarial theory
applies regardless and there's also the
practice and in practice what happens is
when the world is non-stationary you
increase your amount of exploration a
little bit and it copes with that so
even though the world is non-stationary
and so the theory the iad theory doesn't
apply you can still end up doing pretty
good
performance-wise
Macario is good
yeah so there are a lot of techniques
for trying to estimate the probability
in practice I find it really hard to
trust whatever results you get out of
them because they're also due to the
quality of a prediction which you can't
even verify very well what I would
primarily suggest is we go here then you
go here we have a new client library
here which is designed to generate these
probabilities so get them to use this
and then you get the probabilities right
so this might seem like a faff answer
but I've been frustrated many times
trying to work with the existing data if
you just have the wrong data then it's
just it's so much worse than actually
having the right data and and this is a
client library which is designed to
collect the right data and that makes it
much much easier to start being
productive another question
yeah so yeah so we've applied in
situations where the relatively small
those editors are not actually useless
they actually have a real value the real
value is choosing what the top 20
articles are and then the system is
trying to optimize which one you're most
interested in no it doesn't start from
scratch so we use action dependent
features so if you feature eyes your
articles in the right way then it'll
carry over from past articles yeah
okay let me show you one last thing and
then we'll give it a rap let's go here
okay so this is contextual bandit data
so this was generated by using the same
supervisor set so we had we're using the
same ground troops as before and what's
happening is
there's a action that was taken
there's the costs of that action so
we're operating in a loss basis rather
than a reward basis and there's a
probability we lose to that excellent
state so I think that initially we just
randomly have to choose action warm
several times but then later we choose
action too and sometimes we see a loss
of one's nose we see a loss of zero this
is a the label information here is
different the label information here is
what you get out of the for the purpose
of training a contextual bandit policy
right now we can say oh we have a
contextual bandit with two actions and
I'm going to use the same flags as
before to Train right so the system is
operating by reduction to the same base
learning algorithm so and we're using
the same kinds of flags you expect
similar performance except for whatever
issues there are associated with erasing
information when do you get axle-back
because you have less information you
only have the loss of the action that
was actually taken not implicitly the
loss of all actions so there's less
information available and yet still you
can see that our performance is not that
bad
we're down to five percent error rate
and it will get better you can see that
the system is working harder because
there's a bit more work involved in
reducing this down to a supervised
learning solution but nevertheless we
give pretty good performance so I'm
trying to show you here is that it's
extremely practical to solve potential
bandit problems along the lines that
were used to with supervised learning
and that means you can you can go out
and you're free to solve new kinds of
problems that you just you maybe didn't
even know that you could solve
previously
anyway yeah yeah okay so the name
Jabberwocky is one part the Elmore flood
is no one in the last part let's see if
I can do this
let's go here
search for
Euler rabbit
yeah it's a mood not getting sound
because oh no here we go here we go here
yes
so in Jabberwocky there's a vorpal sword
which is where the word burple comes
from to the nonsense word this is the
kind of appointed poem but you never
Latino it's a very sharp sword from
context
all right so that's the third reference
in the name
oh so I think you're asking is can you
do contextual bandits or instead of
having discrete actions you have if you
get to news action yeah
so the answer is yes and the answer is
no it's not in V W and the answer is we
actually have a paper that were
submitting to Colt in three days which
is trying to crack a big part of its
trying to make it these things much more
practical so that's an active research
area so this finished it's four point
seven percent who is 4.5 percent doing
supervised learning give you a sense of
how close it is yeah
how's it compared to adding a
randomization into your training data so
the purpose of adding randomization into
your training data is usually for
regularization purposes all right so
you're adding it in to make sure you
make it less likely to overfit
I see so so you can even add a
randomization into your training data
and you can learn a policy and you can
deploy it and then it will go and it
will do something and then you'll feed
the data back into your learning
algorithm I mean we're trying to do the
same thing but we're trying to do it in
a more scientific way right so we try to
add just the randomization which is
required only the randomization which is
required in order to give you the
performance that you want to get all
right so I guess I would regard that as
flying by the seat of your pants
well well here we actually have theory
behind the algorithms and we know that
we'll be able to converge in an
effective fashion and another thing
which is happening here is that if you
add or a musician to training data
they'll get out a model then you won't
know what the implicit distribution over
actions created is so here we create an
explicit distribution over actions
memories you can draw from it when we
can node X with the P should be and so
having that exists but explicit P is
very powerful
it's do it Pato said if you don't know
what that P is you can try to estimate
it and it might work but it's
yeah it's not doing that obviously you
can save the model and do it if you want
but it's not doing that I mean there's
this Python Java C sharp those are the
primary bindings it exists